for a minute reading fell silent
stopping to remember all three victims
of the attack which has left this city
none we now know James furlong Joe Ricci
Bennett and David Wales with a three
young men who were murdered on Saturday
night described as kind funny a joy to
be around the school where James furlong
taught history closed today with
counselors on hand to support students
James was a very kind and gentle man he
had a real sense of duty and cared for
each and every one of our students
he truly inspired everyone he taught he
was a teacher who left a lasting
impression on former pupils he was
always a good positive presence in the
school always came in school the
smartness face and was just willing to
want to teach everyone that came through
his door with a lot of positivity and a
lot of enthusiasm Joe Ricci Bennett's
moved to the UK from America 15 years
ago he'd made a home here the windows to
his flat left open before he made his
way out on Saturday look a very nice guy
to be honest I met he like probably
twice or three times this is where she
met him so full Bri Gardens according to
survivors and witnesses quickly became a
scene of carnage all three men had been
sitting together part of a larger group
Martin Cooper who runs reading pride was
friends with all three you go down this
route of hoping there is a mistake
hoping that they've just lost their
phones in the park in the chaos all that
they're just in hospital being treated
and again sadly that wasn't the case
they would all be together in the same
area in the park and that area is going
to be very lonely the BLA grave arms
where the men drank those that knew them
came to remember their friends it still
isn't clear why the men were targeted
there will be many people from inside
and outside of Redding who may not have
known the victims personally but we feel
like they have lost members of their own
community even though they may live so
many miles apart
reading is a diverse City for the
horrors of Saturday night have seen this
community stand as one cages fences Sky
News